[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans votre 7,8 week end voici les titres
de ce vendredi 27 mai c'est un important
projet pour l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui est en train de
se concrétiser
les murs en béton et les cinq bassins du
futur centre aqualudique intercommunale
elancourt maurepas se dessine le futur
équipement nommé casse talia devraient
être livrés d'ici 2022
nous ferons le point sur l'avancée du
chantier ce jeudi 27 mai se déroulait la
journée nationale de la résistance dans
les yvelines comment sauvegarde ton la
mémoire de cette période
éléments de réponse avec la fondation de
la résistance et son responsable du
département documentation et
publications franz malassis enfin côté
loisirs cette semaine avec cellier
agathe son goût nous irons à la ferme de
gally pour se perdre dans un labyrinthe
et nous vous proposerons aussi des idées
cadeaux pour la fête des mères
[Applaudissements]
c'est un gros projet dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui a fait beaucoup parler le
chantier du futur centre aqualudique
intercommunale elancourt maurepas avance
les murs en béton sont en train d'être
monté les cinq bassins ont déjà pris
forme
on fait le point sur surfe sur ce futur
équipement avec bixente mais rien senti
stéven qu'installe ya c'est le nom du
futur centre aqualudique porté par les
villes de maurepas elancourt débuté avec
un peu de retard les travaux avancent
pour l'instant comme prévu on a passé
toutes les phases d'autorisations
administratives etc qui sont passées
pendant cette période qu vide qu'on a
connu on va livrer à l'été 2022 pour une
activité commerciale a connu dit que
l'important c'est d'ouvrir en été on
respecte cinq bassins dédiés à des
usages variés dont un en extérieur qui
commence à prendre forme dans le
chantier apprentissage baignade sport
santé vous bien être objectif répondre
aux attentes de chacun de manière
justement être sur un équipement qui
sera d'abord durable et qui répond
vraiment aux besoins des différents
types d'usagés que ce soit les scolaires
les associations ou le grand public
manière générale qui cherchent à avoir
une activité soit sportive soit de
détente soit lui dit carrément il est
entouré d'arbres c'est vraiment dans un
écrin de verdure donc très profitable
pour les habitants qui habitent à côté
et qui profiteront en même temps de ne
tout la verdure qui est autour un projet
qui mêle technologies et environnement à
hauteur de 24 millions d'euros dont la
majorité est fournie par le
concessionnaire
le financement public est estimé à 11
millions d'euros il est réparti entre
plusieurs acteurs c'est un bel exemple
de partenariat entre la région qui en
soutien d'un projet de territoire
donc avec l'agglomération effectivement
avec la commune avec le département et
c'est la façon dont nous travaillons
maintenant systématiquement sur tout un
tas de projets la région aide ainsi à
hauteur de 800 mille euros en tant que
porteur du projet l'apport de maurepas
s'élève à 4 millions quatre cent
cinquante mille euros dont un million
quatre cent cinquante mille apportée par
saint quentin en yvelines
la ville d'el encore rapporte quant à
elle 2 millions neuf cent soixante cinq
mille euros
pour les futurs nageurs l'entrée à cast
alia ne sera pas aussi élevé les
résidents des deux communes paieront 5
euros 40 pour les autres le tarif sera
de 6 euros 95
comme je vous le disais en titre ce
jeudi 27 mai avait lieu la journée
nationale de la résistance une journée
pour rendre hommage à ceux qui ont
résisté durant la seconde guerre
mondiale aux nazis pour en parler nous
accueillons en visioconférence avec nous
franz malassis bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes le chef du département
documentation et publication au sein de
la fondation de la résistance
tout d'abord un peu d'histoire on va
rappeler le contexte cette journée
nationale de la résistance hal fait
référence à la première réunion du
conseil national de la résistance le cnr
qui s'est déroulée le 27 mai 1943 jean
moulin célèbre résistant souhaité
instaurer ce conseil dans le but
d'unifier les divers mouvements de
résistance qui était souvent
désorganisés pour pouvoir justement
coordonner la résistance dans la france
entière alors franz maladie en quoi est
ce important de célébrer cette journée
je pense que comme lire cet armement
d'unification dans la résistance
française voulu par général devant le
pour justement renforcée et sel et donc
c'est jean moulin qui emploie paris
occupé ou du four va créer organiser et
rassembler donc les représentants de la
résistance ce sont des mouvements des
partis politiques clandestins le site
des syndicats et c'est un moment d'unité
nationale pourquoi parce que après la
guerre est bien le programme qu'ils vont
mettre en place en mars 1944 pour
achever la guerre mais aussi pour mettre
en place des réformes socio-économiques
donc pour rétablir l'ordre républicain
mais aussi modifier les structures
sociales et économiques de la france
vont être véritablement un moment de
cohésion nationale un grand moment de
cohésion nationale il faut savoir que
les ordonnances vont mettre en place la
sécurité sociale mais aussi qu'ils vont
nationalisée
les billets vont être votées par
l'ensemble des représentants donc de
l'état afin de les représentants
politiques
donc depuis la gauche jusqu'à la droite
traditionnelle
donc c'est véritablement un moment
d'union un moment de communion
on peut le comparer avec le 14 juillet
que nous célébrons puisque le 14 juillet
fête à la fois la prise de la bastille
mais aussi la confédération dont
vraiment des grands moments d'unité
nationale alors cette journée c'est
aussi l'occasion d'être donc unifiée
vous l'avez dit mais c'est aussi de
véhiculer certaines valeurs notamment le
souci constant de la justice la
solidarité la tolérance ou encore le
respect d'autrui
c'est des valeurs qui font encore écho
aujourd'hui selon vous bien sûr bien sûr
il faut savoir que depuis soixante ans
existe un concours parce qu'on appelle
le concours national de la résistance et
de la déportation
créée en 1961 a donc officialisé en 1961
par l'éducation nationale mais qui a été
voulue en fait par des résistants à
partir de 1955 et ce concours justement
permet d'une part de transmettre les le
l'héritage mais comme vous les
transmettre les résistants aux jeunes
mais aussi de transmettre les valeurs
qui sous-tendent est leur combat les
valeurs de justice sociale n'est le
rappeler mais aussi des valeurs de
l'égalité
il faut savoir que les résistants n'ont
pas fait que combattre par les armes les
nazis mais ils ont voulu rétablir aussi
les libertés fondamentales et rétablir
la république c'est le retour justement
de l'état républicain et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très important
c'est un combat moral à combat par les
armes de l'esprit mais surtout un combat
moral pour rétablir la république
et ça je pense que par ce concours que
ces associations ont mis en place et qui
se perdu aujourd'hui
et bien c'est un moyen de rappeler
justement les valeurs qu'il y avait
derrière leur combat il faut savoir que
c'est un concours qui est national
il ya un vide sur la base du partenariat
du volontariat pardon les collégiens et
lycéens de tout
la france a participé dans les yvelines
on a et demande énormément de
participation moi même je participe au
jury départemental et sommes en cours a
aussi une particularité c'est peut-être
moins vrai maintenant mais c'est de se
faire rencontrer des départs les acteurs
de la résistance avec des jeunes
c'est une rencontre interne
intergénérationnel assez unique et je
tiens à saluer là présentement le
chacune fleury est une une actrice du
résistante déportée
j'étais très jeune à l'époque et qui a
été vraiment dans les pionnières à
animer ce concours au niveau national et
elle est toujours avec nous pour animer
ce concours dans les départements des
yvelines
et justement on reprend cet entretien
dans un instant france malassis pour
continuer à enseigner ces valeurs le
mardi 4 mai dernier
la procureure de la république maryvonne
caillibotte et le président du tribunal
judiciaire de versailles ont signé une
convention avec la fondation mémorial de
la shoah objectif prévoir des stages en
cas de condamnation pour racisme ou
antisémitisme
on écoute justement la procureure de la
république de versailles
[Musique]
il s'agit en fait d'un stage de
citoyenneté
particulier qui est destiné à un public
concerné par des infractions en lien
avec eux le racisme et l'antisémitisme
et les stages de citoyenneté qui est une
procédure qui est prévue depuis très
très longtemps puisque ça existe depuis
2003 ne cesse en fait de se développer
en le stage est prévu sur deux jours
il est gratuit il se déroule au mémorial
de la shoah dans le marais à paris qui
est donc d'abord un musée mais ils vont
également rencontrer des rescapés du
génocide par exemple du génocide des
tutsi donc ils vont directement
confrontés à des paroles de personnes
qui ont été concernés par le racisme
notamment où l'antisémitisme
l'intérêt de ce stage c'est que
effectivement maintenant on peut le
prononcé à tous les stades justement de
la procédure soit ce qu'on appelle en
pré sentenciel donc en alternative aux
poursuites soient en poste sont en ciel
c'est à dire lorsque le tribunal a
considéré que c'était une des modalités
d'application de la peine
[Musique]
par la voix de la pédagogie en réalité à
sensibiliser expliquer faire comprendre
c'est de prendre conscience de ce que
leur expression qui peut être écrite qui
peut utiliser les réseaux sociaux peu
importe le support a donc d' illégale et
qu'elle ne peut pas perdurer pour que
les citoyens et la possibilité de vivre
les uns avec les autres donc c'est
apprendre la tolérance à prendre
l'interdît ou réapprendre l'interdît
nous sommes toujours donc en
visioconférence avec notre invité de 7,8
week-end france malassis très rapidement
que pensez-vous de cette initiative
fransman assis à mes côtés je crois
c'est une très bonne initiative de voir
quelles sont les racines du mal donc le
rappeler sont aux jeunes ce qu'est ce
que l'histoire
là on voit avec ce partenariat avec la
fondation pour la shoah
donc le fait de rencontrer des témoins
n'ont pas dû du génocide de la seconde
guerre mondiale mais aussi tout ci s'est
montré aussi que eh bien c'est quelque
chose qui malheureusement est une est un
phénomène qui frappe l humanité sur tout
le xxème siècle ne pas l'enfermer dans
une période historique mais montrer que
justement d'axer ses formes de tolérance
extrême sont les génocides sont toujours
condamnés toujours condamné notamment
par le tribunal pénal international
quinio ça ne c'est toujours quelque
chose qui fait da qui fait suite d'un
cirque il ya toujours une condamnation
qui est qui est opérée et je pense que
c'est bien de le révoquer
quelle est l'histoire de ceux de cet
antisémitisme aussi de leur parler
également de ce qu'ont vécu des
générations pendant la guerre ces
générations donc victime de la shoah et
de montrer que leur parole pour un sens
terre avant d'être déportés d'avray
exterminés eh bien il ya toujours un
élément de propagande c'est ce que l'on
me les nazis en avant pour ostraciser
les juifs et ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose dont il faut les ai
conscience
leurs paroles les engage mais ça je
crois que c'est un très beau travail
donner des injonctions à des jeunes ça
n'a pas toujours forcément une porte et
c'est bien mais leur montrer les
conséquences que peuvent avoir leurs
actes et leurs paroles surtout ça je
pense que ça peut être très formateur et
je soutiens dont j'étais au courant de
cette initiative je trouve que c'est une
très bonne initiative car elle fait
preuve de pédagogie je pense que en
histoire c'est toujours ce qu'il faut
faire peur preuve de pédagogie
c'est en isner historiens c'est
expliquer les faits expliqué les hanches
et les cheminements qui ont amené avec
conséquences aussi désastreuses que le
génocide
c'est justement le rôle de la fondation
de la résistance merci en tout cas à
vous france malassis d'avoir été avec
nous pour ce cette suite week end et
après une semaine bien chargée quoi de
mieux que de se détendre le week-end
comme chaque vendredi c'est 400 go vous
propose ses idées sorties et loisirs
[Musique]
cette semaine nous allons nous perdre au
labyrinthe à la ferme de gally à
saint-cyr-l'ecole leurs quatre
labyrinthe ont rouvert avec deux mois
d'avancé jusqu'au 30 octobre
ils accueilleront adultes et enfants les
mercredis et les week-ends de 10h30 à
18h30
bérengère bourgoin il est allé faire un
tour pour nous on a commencé là on a
hâte on a fait ça ouais on est là à peu
près donc la sortie c'est tout différent
par rapport à l'année dernière le
labyrinthe des ou qu'ils aient des
illusions d'optique celui des tracteurs
ou encore des légumes sont accessibles à
partir de 3 ans dès le mois de juin de
nouveaux labyrinthes viendront s'ajouter
à cette liste
mais ces différents labyrinthes donc
penser à 5 sont au nombre de quatre
c'est des petits labyrinthes de petits
pour les enfants et 2 qui sont les plus
grands qui ne peuvent pas faire seul
tout au long de leur parcours les
visiteurs doivent résoudre de petites
énigmes
je m'attendais pas ce qui est des
petites des petits panneaux avec des
questions pour les enfants donc à
l'entrée on nous donne une petite
feuille pour répondre à des questions
donc sa team hante le parcours de
plaintes petite pause ludique c'est très
chouette des labyrinthes qui ne sont pas
si simples
au début fin j'ai vu quelqu'un il ya une
technique en fait faut toujours posé sa
main droite sur les sur les aime et on
arrivera toujours à la sortie du coup
j'ai essayé mais ça m'a ramené un
cul-de-sac
on souhaite un autre jeu ça marche pas
qui trouve le réconfort après l'effort
les visiteurs peuvent faire une pause
gourmande
après les labyrinthes alors le point des
gourmands donc c'est plusieurs petites
choses qu'on va vendre ici
en même temps que labyrinthes du coup
donc on a les glaces quand il fait beau
et chaud sinon on a donc comme vous le
voyez derrière moi donc plutôt des
petites gourmandises chaude donc des
beignets des madeleines des pancartes
des voyages perdus à partir du 7 juillet
les labyrinthes seront ouverts tous les
jours des nocturnes avec des soirées
barbecues seront organisés sur
réservation dimanche c'est la fête des
mères les plus organisés d'entre vous
ont déjà leurs cadeaux depuis plusieurs
jours
bixente n'a rien senti stevan bonsoir
alors vous vous avez pensé aux
retardataires et vous nous donner
quelques idées c'est ah oui exactement
la fête des mères c'est une journée si
particulière où pour une fois ce sont
les enfants qui prennent soin de leur
maman après une pas une année passée
enfermé chez soi ce sont surtout des
cadeaux type activités qui seront
plébiscités si vous sentez que votre
mère a besoin de se détendre un petit
peu vous pouvez d'ores et déjà réserver
un massage en soins au spa de l'hôtel de
la corniche harold boss ou encore à
l'atelier de massage à versailles par
exemple avec le beau temps j'imagine
qu'on peut faire aussi des activités en
extérieur exactement celle ya donc il ya
le déjà re devenu classique restant en
terrasse mais on peut aussi aller
chercher dans le plus original il existe
des ateliers pour découvrir les trésors
de la nature ça s'appelle le temps de
savoir faire plusieurs activités sont
proposées il dure de deux à sept heures
dans la forêt de marly et alors qu'elle
est l'atelier le plus susceptible de
plaire aux mamans c'est probablement là
la découverte des plantes comestibles
une petite balade pour apprendre à ne
pas se tromper entre les différents
produits de la nature
brémond flamand fondateur du temps des
savoir-faire nous en parle apprendre à
être vraiment à l'aise sur la
reconnaissance de plantes sauvages
comestibles et ensuite comment les
préparant cuisine parce qu'en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la plupart
des plantes qui sont qu'on peut trouver
dans une forêt comme la forêt de marly
dans laquelle on fait les animations
c'est des plantes parfois qui sont
utilisés dans les plus grands
restaurants gastronomiques puisqu'ils
ont des goûts qui sont assez inattendue
est un peu un peu oublier d'autres
activités comme la découverte de la
vannerie de l'argile la fabrication
d'objets comme le hochet ou une cuillère
en bois sont proposés pour les prix il
varie de 10
à 79 euros donc adaptable à tous les
budgets vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le temps de savoir
faire point com et comme cerise sur le
gâteau ou plutôt sur le cadeau un petit
bouquet de fleurs ne serait pas trop
hein oui une très bonne idée il ya
d'autant qu'il ya une fleur à la mode
pour cette fête des mères c'est la
pivoine 4int phalempin gérante des
fleurs du manet à montigny le bretonneux
nous explique pourquoi c'est parce que
c'est une fleur qui est très en vogue
depuis quelques années et c'est une
fleur que nous avons en gros pendant un
mois
souvent elles commencent au nom à la
fête des mères nous les clients ont
pratiquement toute l'année nous
demandent des pivoines les roses nous en
avons toute l'année la pivoine c'est un
mois alors on revient souvent souvent
sur la pivoine on en profite puisque ça
dure pas longtemps
attention cependant les stocks de ce
dimanche risque d'être un peu limité
avec le mauvais temps de mais la saison
sera sûrement décalé d'environ deux
semaines
rien ne vous empêche cependant de vous
rabattre sur d'autres classiques comme
les orchidées ou les roses qui font
aussi leur petit effet merci beaucoup un
vicente pour toutes ces idées et alors
est ce que vous aimez de l'astronomie
je vous plaint de perdre de temps en
temps mais ça s'arrête là pour tout dire
eh ben c'est très bien parce que en fait
le donjon de houdan l'astronomie est mis
en valeur et mise en lumière jusqu'au
1er septembre des expositions seront
présentées
marthe des prêts bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes animatrice du patrimoine au donjon
de ou dans la journée du samedi 29 mai
sera consacré à âtre en ile de france
le projet promouvoir le lien entre la
société l'école la recherche en
astronomie alors trois ateliers seront
accessibles au grand public un c'est
bien ça tout à fait trois ateliers il y
aura un atelier exoplanète un atelier
météorites et un atelier planétaire
d'accord alors en quoi ça consistait
trois ateliers l'atelier planétaire par
exemple qu'est ce que c'est un plein
déterminant alors à peine d'être humains
en fait ça se sait sous forme de grandes
bâches sur lequel il y a destiné en fait
les orbites des planètes autour du
soleil
et selon un rythme chacun un cas une
planète et passe d'un point
autre pour en fait refaire le tour du
soleil en fonction de son éloignement
par rapport au soleil et donc en
fonction de sa vitesse donc il y aura
cinq planètes plus une comète donc les
visiteurs pourront incarner une comète
et faire le tour du soleil et les
visiteurs qui regardent vont pouvoir en
fait constaté le mouvement des planètes
autour du soleil
et puis ensuite on échangera il y aura
les observateurs d'un côté et il y aura
ceux qui feront les planètes de l'autre
ça c'est pour le planétaire et ce sont
des ateliers pour les enfants
adapté pour les enfants oui alors à
partir du cp on va dire donc ce sont des
ateliers aussi bien pour les enfants que
pour les adultes les trois l'atelier
exoplanètes et à un petit peu plus
technique donc c'est peut-être plus pour
les adultes
mais si les enfants sont là les adultes
peuvent ensuite reprendre l'explication
et puis les animateurs des associations
qui sont là et donc qui ont porté ce
projet dassault en ile-de-france seront
là et savent très bien s'adapter aux
différents publics
et justement c'est qui qui sont faits
d'animateur alors c'est l'association
ace à chaud et l'association vigie ciel
et l'association la société astronomique
de france qui seront là et puis
l'association le donjon de houdan donc
qui en fait tu reçois avec plaisir
toutes ces associations pour parler
d'astronomie
alors il ya aussi une conférence avec
l'astre au graff jean-françois gelli
dimanche 30 mai à 17 heures est-ce que
vous pouvez un peu m'en parler voilà
alors jean-françois j'ai dit c'est un
astrophotographe et il est animateur
scientifique à l'observatoire de saint
véran dans le terrain il fait des photos
très technique de paysages nocturnes
ce qui est quand même pas évident parce
qu'il faut à la fois photographié le
ciel de nuit est à la fois photographié
l'environnement
il ya autour donc ce sont des très
belles photos de montagne donc il va
nous expliquer comment il réalise ses
photos lors de cette conférence et vous
avez aussi une exposition permanente la
place de l'humain dans l'espace et le
temps
de quoi s'agit-il alors il s'agit de
redonner la place de l'humain dans
l'espace et le temps
parce que moi qui fais de l'astronomie
de pied 20 ans qui suis animatrice
scientifique
je me suis rendu compte que les gens
vous n'avez pas une bonne idée de la
façon dont les choses sont avant son
agence est aussi bien dans l'espace dans
cet univers qui paraît absolument
immense et en même temps dans le temps
parce que on a du mal à se situer un
petit peu donc j'ai voulu faire cette
exposition pour redonner place de
l'humain dans cet espace qui à la fois
très grand et dans ce temps qui nous
semblent infinies c'est une façon de se
réapproprier un peu le ciel en montrant
qu'on en fait partie
que nous sommes réellement des enfants
de l'univers et des enfants des étoiles
et en même temps peut-être prendre un
peu de recul justement sur l'existence
de l'espèce humaine pour peut-être
acquérir un peu plus de sagesse et de
modestie et moins pensé qu' on est le
centre du monde et que on occupe une
planète plus que les autres espèces par
exemple donc ça a un petit côté un peu
philosophique et puis un petit côté
aussi un peu écologique aussi quelque
part et donc l'exposition est à
retrouver jusqu'au 1er septembre un fait
ça tout à fait donc donjon jusqu'au 1er
septembre
très bien merci beaucoup mart des prix
d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page vous dire je
vous propose des idées de sorties pour
ce week end le golf national à
guyancourt lance une nouvelle fois sa
grande braderie le 28 29 et 30 mai de 9
heures à 18 heures 45 le dimanche de 9h
à 16h des milliers d'articles seront à
prix réduit les plus grandes marques de
golf seront représentés pour des remises
jusqu'à -60% et l'émission continue avec
eléonore pour parler de l'actualité
[Musique]
comme chaque semaine votre rendez-vous
en partenariat avec les surligneurs on
écoute vincent couronne fondateur et
surligneurs et docteur en droit à
l'université versailles saint quentin
une fois n'est pas coutume je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui d'un homme politique
qui a dit quelque chose de plutôt vrai
enfin ce qu'il a dit interroge sur
l'adéquation entre le droit et
l'application du droit
le garde des sceaux eric dupond-moretti
puisque c'est de lui dont il s'agit a
réagi à une accusation de laxisme de
l'opposition en matière de protection
des femmes victimes de violences
conjugales
cela faisait suite au meurtre de cette
femme à mérignac brûlée vive par son
mari le ministre de la justice a déclaré
à l'assemblée nationale que son
gouvernement en avait fait bien plus que
les gouvernements précédents en matière
de protection face aux violences
conjugales
si on regarde du strict point de vue du
droit il a tort car parmi les mesures
qu'il cite l'ordonance d'éloignement du
conjoint violent a été mise en place en
2004 sous la présidence de jacques
chirac le bracelet anti rapprochement en
2010 par nicolas sarkozy et le téléphone
grave danger lui a été mise en place par
françois hollande en 2014
mais du point de vue de l'application de
ces mesures il a plutôt raison tant ces
dispositifs ont manqué de moyens ou été
mal calibré par les gouvernements
précédents
le gouvernement actuel a
considérablement renforcé ses outils
le bracelet peut être désormais imposé
avant la condamnation du conjoint
violent
le téléphone peut être fourni à une
personne en danger sans attendre une
mesure d'éloignement du conjoint
quant à l'éloignement du conjoint
justement il doit être décidée plus
rapidement alors qu'est ce que cette
affaire nous dit de notre droit d'une
part que toute nouvelle mesure est
rarement parfaite
il faut du temps pour voir ses effets
pour éventuellement l'adapter
mais aussi et surtout adopter une mesure
sérieuse et efficace ça prend du temps
ce que les citoyens qui veulent une
réponse rapide ont souvent du mal à
admettre et ça réclame des moyens ce que
le politique à lui du mal à prévoir
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week-end merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine passé une très bonne
soirée un très bon week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ans
oh
[Musique]